[Music]
hey everybody I figured I'd mix it up
today I'm gonna do a little bit of
juggling tutorial for everybody and I
think you might really enjoy this I
really like juggling in this particular
style of juggling can we do down a lot
of different pathways and it's on-body
juggling so this is me on Bodwell with
our Russians in a while I just decided
to use these
this is a basic on body double maybe
you've heard of on the Internet the term
BBB which is this guy okay and so how to
learn that well first off these are
fairly large Spears so I would probably
recommend getting some Russians or some
beanbags that will help you get started
we're gonna start with two in one hand
and one in the other and a real big tip
I learned this first from Brian Thompson
and he's got some real amazing skills
with this kind of stuff so first thing
is if your arms are straight to touch
your body if you leave any space between
here and here the balls will sort of
slip out of that space so you want to
kind of keep your elbow straight for the
most part and try to keep your whole
forearm touching your body the entire
time and then the next step with two and
one and two and the other is to pass
them really slowly and this is kind of
annoying at first but once you get it
really slow let me start giving a little
more of a hop and you notice keeping
this attached to your body your arm
stuck to your body will be the most
challenging part your body arms
constantly want to adjust to catch the
ball but stay like this I'm going to
start popping them up a water
and I kind of aim for here kind of gets
me a little further and then when I feel
ready
I do the on-body pretty cool all right
and then you can also do things like
showers which it's a lot harder with
these larger Spears so there's a shower
you can you can I like the dropping into
it is really nice I'm like juggling okay
all right well there's some artistic
pretend juggling for you well again
thanks oh my patreon hopefully this can
be a fun way to get started with
juggling just to remind you the steps
for arms to body
don't move past them really slowly kind
of use your hand as little flippers more
in the fingers see how my fingers are
like get them over so a little higher
and eventually after even after two days
ten minutes a day you'll be feeling some
differences and you notice I kind of got
this lean back that's good but just be
careful with your back I've been
actually doing this one it's kind of
cool just like shoulder pads alright
thank you
[Music]
you